l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
Gouvernement la
première va être posé par madame la
Présidente Panau pour le groupe la
France
insoumise présidente madame la Première
ministre hier vous avez été défait vous
et tous les semeurs de haine hier votre
loi immigration a été batue par
l'assemblée du jamais vu en 25 ans hier
nous sommes fier d'avoir épargné au pays
de semaines de déchaînement de paroles
racistes et xénophobes celles qui
diviseent le peuple celles qui permettre
les passages à l'acte de la tentative
d'égorgement de mourade aux expéditions
punitives racistes à roman sur iser hier
comme demain nous serons toujours les
gardiens de l'unité du peuple hier nous
sommes fiers de vous avoir rappelé que
la France n'a jamais été une nation
ethnique mais sera toujours une nation
politique fondée sur la promesse li
égalité
fraternité hier vous avez été défait
après un président élu par défaut une
Premier ministre sans confiance vous
voilà à la tête d'un gouvernement
minoritaire sans légitimité
parlementaire ni populaire hier votre
Ministre de l'Intérieur a osé parler de
dénis de démocratie le dénis de
démocratie c'est vous 20 493 2 ans de
vie vol au français contre l'immense
majorité du
peupleamere ministre 1493 vous n'êtes
rien si ce n'est un gouvernement
incapable incapable de légiférer et de
gouverner hier vous avait osé dire que
l'assemblée s'était déshonorée et ne
représentait pas les Français mais les
Français veulent des augmentations de
salaire une véritable politique contre
la vie chère des services publics qui
assurent l'égalité des citoyens ils
veulent en finir avec un gouvernement
qui a fait régresser la France à l'état
d'un pays qui a faim dans toutes les
démocraties quand un ministre est battu
il doit démissionner
[Applaudissements]
estadame la prère ministre sentez-vous
cette odeur de fin de règne tôt ou tard
vous serez contraint de retourner aux
urnes le peuple devra alors choisir
entre le camp des élites racistes ou
celui de l'Union Populaire madame la
Première ministre partez le plus vite
possibleci beaucoup madame la
Présidente votre temp est
écoulé à madame la Première
ministre merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la Présidente Mathilde
Panau hier une fois de plus vous vous
êtes coalisé avec le rassemblement
national
hier hier une fois de plus vous avez
fait le choix délibéré de la
compromission avec l'extrême droite
vous qui souhaitez l'immigration vous
qui souhaitez l'immigration sans règle
vous avez voté avec des partisans de
l'immigration zéro vous qui souhaitez
des régularisations massive vous avez
voté avec ceux qui prôent la fermeture
des frontières et pour quel résultat
madame la Présidente panneau malgré vos
tentatives d'empêcher la discussion le
débat parlementaire va se poursuivre
commission mixte paritaire vaêtre va
être convoqué malgré vos tentatives pour
empêcher le débat nous ne renoncerons
pas à apporter des mesures fortes pour
nos
concitoyensil vous plaît je pense que
définitivement le débat ça n'est pas
pour vous alors madame la Présidente
panneau hormis quelques
[Applaudissements]
secondes non mais vous êtes fâché avec
la démocratie madame la Présidente
panneau et votre groupe
avec
alors madame la Présidente panneau hormi
quelques secondes de satisfaction à
l'Assemblée et quelques minutes
d'attention dans les médias qu'avez-vous
obtenu finalement madame la Présidente
panneau par votre attitude et celle de
votre groupe ceux qui sont pénalisés ce
sont les Français les Français qui
soutiennent très largement notre
texte les Français qui attendent que
nous prenions des mesures fortes pour
réduire l'immigration illégale et pour
mieux intégrer les personnes que nous
choisissons d'accueillir les Français
qui veulent que nous trouvions des
compromis pas des coups politiques à la
petite semaine mais vous que leur
proposez-vous vous ne leur proposez que
le blocage de nos institutions vous ne
leur proposer qu'une union sacrée entre
la nupes et l'extrême droite vous neur
proposez que le ch c'est irresponsable
c'est dangereux et avec le ministre
Gérald daranin et tout mon gouvernement
nous choisirons toujours le chemin de
l'action et de la responsabilité au
service des Français je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Première
[Applaudissements]
ministre la parole est à monsieur le
Président vot pour le groupe
socialiste
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre depuis 18 mois nous avons dans
cette hémicycle au Sénat dans la presse
ou en commission débattu largement de
l'immigration sujet important au
français le débat a bien eu lieu nous y
avons pour notre part largement
participé en cherchant les moyens de
remettre le bon ordre dans le grand
bazar de votre politique migratoire à
régulariser celles et ceux qui
travaillent déjà à remettre en route
l'intégration républicaine mais le texte
que le gouvernement sapêta à défendre
très éloigné des positions d'Emmanuel
Macron en 2017 que nous avons fait par
deux fois élire face à l'extrême droite
vous devez vous en souvenir très éloigné
de sa version initiale de l'ambition
même que vous étiez donné en matière de
régularisation par le travail aveugle à
la question de l'intégration sans
équilibre s'agissant des questions
d'éloignement et qui menac gravement
d'être inefficace et inutile il ntait
plus qu'un mauvais texte de loi de
police des étrangers le rejet de ce
texte hier soir Madame la première
ministre c'est votre seul échec c'est
celui de votre Ministre ce n'est pas la
gauche qui vous précipite dans les bras
de la droite qui elle-même se jette dans
les bras de l'extrême droite parce que
le pacte funeste c'est celui noué au
Sénat par votre Ministre avec la droite
qui porte le programme du rassemblement
national et pour elle ça ne sera jamais
assez mais la crise politique madame la
Première ministre n'est pas dans le
rejet de votre texte mais dans le
passage en force dans le HCl d'une CMP
annoncée dans l'héris d'un débat qui a
donné avoir le pire de lui-même dans le
fait de ne pas croire à la possibilité
d'un débat apaisé rationnel qui seul
permet d'envisager les consensus
républicains renouvelés sur ce sujet
votre devoir est de rassurer d'apaiser
de rassembler madame la Première
ministre je vous le demande sans
outrance sans CR sans la satisfaction du
spectacle de la chute retirer ce texte
qui ne satisfait personne avant d'êtreé
sur une pente et sur un territoire qui
n'est pas le vôtre et que d'autres
utilis contre la République contre
l'État de droit contre la
France je vous remercie la parole est à
madame la Première
ministre merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le président Boris vot hier
vous avez fait un choix lourd de
conséquence pour un coup politique sans
lendemain vous avez mis de côtés vos
convictions vous avez choisi de mêler
vos voix à celle de l'extrême droite
vous avez mis de
côté vous avez mis de côté des décennies
d'histoire du Parti socialiste pour
refuser le débat en vous appuyant sur le
rassemblement
national vous étiez un parti de
gouvernement hier vous avez fait le
choix de
l'irresponsabilité
vous ne cessez d'invoquer la démocratie
parlementaire et le rôle de l'Assemblée
nationale c'est vous qui avez balayer
d'un revers de main le texte adopté par
la commission des lois c'est vous qui
empêchez le débat sur les 200600
amendements que nous devions étudier
ensemble monsieur le président Boris
Valot les français demandent des
solutions face au défi migratoire nous
sommes déterminés à les donner alors vos
manœuvres n'y feront rien nous gardons
le cap une commission mixte paritaire va
être convoquée nous ne renoncerons
jamais à trouver des compromis nous ne
renoncerons jamais à apporter les
solutions attendues par les Français la
fermeté face à l'immigration irrégulière
et une meilleure intégration de celles
et ceux que nous accueillons avec la
majorité nous continuerons à agir pour
apporter des réponses aux
Français je vous remercie madame la
Première ministre
la parole est à Madame edvich Diaz pour
le rassemblement
national merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à madame la Première
ministre hier le en même temps si cher à
Emmanuel Macron a montré ses limites et
s soldé par un véritable camouflé pour
votre gouvernement alors que les
Français expriment leur volonté d'une
baisse drastique de l'immigration dans
notre pays comme d'habitude vous ne les
avez pas écouté et au contraire vous
avez proposé un texte qui aurait permis
la création de nouvelles filières
d'immigration la répartition de migrants
dans nos campagnes et la régularisation
massive de clandestins voilà pourquoi
les députés du rassemblement national
ont voté pour la motion de rejet
néanmoins il y avait dans ce texte
quelques mesures de bon sens qu'au
rassemblement national nous réclamons
depuis des années je pense en
particulier à celle qui vise à supprimer
les dérogations existantes dans notre
droit qui nous empêche d'expulser un
délinquent étranger si l'on en croit les
courriers reçus par les Parlement en fin
de semaine dernière ce genre d'expulsion
constitue une priorité pour votre
gouvernement alors qu'en 6 ans vous
n'aurez pas été capable de vous saisir
de ce sujet extrêmement préoccupant pour
nos concitoyens Marine Le Pen dans son
esprit constructif et sincèrement
soucieux de la sécurité des Français a
déposé ce matin un texte permettant
précisément de lever ses dérogation
d'après les déclarations de nombreux
collègues cette proposition de loi elle
devrait bénéficier d'un soutien
transpartisan alors ma question est la
suivante allez-vous demander son étude
dans les prochains jours je vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
à Monsieur géralde d'manin ministre de
l'Intérieur et des
outremes merci madame la Présidente
mesdames et messieurs les députés madame
diz s'il y a bien eu en même temps c'est
en même temps entre le vote du
rassemblement national et celui de
laanupes Madame Diaz le non débat d'hier
a démontré d'une chose d'abord c'est que
vous avez peur du
débat vous n'avez pas voulu parler
d'immigration vous en parlez dans les
meetings dans les marchés sur les
tractes vous en parlez sur les plateaux
de télévision mais vous n'en parlez
jamais devant la représentation
nationale parce que vous avez eu
peur et c'est tellement vrai que votre
belle unité de façade entre les
contraires entre vos amis mélanchonistes
et vous-même entre ceux qui veulent
accueillir tout le monde et ceux qui
veulent accueillir personne fait que dès
le lendemain vous proposez exactement
les mêmes dispositions que le
gouvernement pour lutter contre les
étrangers délinquants trouver l'erreur
merci merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre madame
Diaz merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre vous fignez d'ignorer ce
qu'est une motion de rejet très
sincèrement ça n'est pas au niveau et je
pense que les Français continueront de
vous le reprocher mais moi j'ai une
dernière question pour vous monsieur le
ministre qui a peur du débat moi je
pense que c'est vous qui refusez de
proposer au français un
référendum je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre
vous auriez pu débattre ici et
maintenant plutôt que réclamer un débat
vous auriez pu l'accepter DS
hier vous êtes
incohérent comme d'habitude le
rassemblement national vit des problèmes
et ne veut aucune des solutions vous
avez désarmé nos policiers hier vous
avez désarmé nos préfets vous désarmez
les Français et vous allez vous réjouir
au prochain fait d'hiver vous faites la
politique
vous faites la politique du dén et vous
faites malheureusement la politique du
pire parce que ce qui vous intéresse
c'est la France qui ne réussit pas ce
qui nous intéresse c'est la France qui
trouve des solutions nous soutenons nos
policiers n gendarmes nous nous
soutenons nos préfets vous vous faites
que de la politique
politicienne je vous remercie monsieur
le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Philippe Pradal pour le groupe horizon
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres chers
collègues le groupe Horizon est déçu
déçu que l'Assemblée nationale a été
privé d'un débat pourtant si important
pour la France et les
Français nous sommes convaincus que ce
texte voté au Sénat et en commission des
loistient des sent néaire pour notre
pays pour notre sécurité pour notre
souveraineté et plus encore conforme au
souhait de nos
concitoyens ce sont 86% des Français qui
sont favorables par exemple à
l'expulsion des délincants étrangers à
l'issue de leur peine de prison il faut
agir et ce projet est une pierre
indispensable à l'édifice de la
réconciliation entre le discours
politique et l'action publique il
l'administration et la justice de
prendre les décisions nécessaires à la
préservation de notre cohésion
sociale une clique qui n'est d'accord
sur rien c'est coalisé pour refuser le
débat au sein de cet hémicycle et
j'espère qu'une majorité de conviction
se dégagera pour adopter un texte de
responsabilité d'efficacité et c'est
soucieux de l'intérêt général que le
groupe horizon et apparenté le
soutiendra sur ce chemin sinueux dev
nous nous devons d'être à la hauteur de
notre devoir et de ne pas jouer avec les
fractures de notre pays monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur ma question est
la suivante quel chemin emprunter pour
répondre à l'inquiétude légitime des
Français en matière de politique
migratoire après l'adoption de la motion
de rejet préalable
hier je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Gérald ministre de l'Intérieur
et des
outr merci mad madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs députés monsieur
le député Pradal je veux vous remercier
ainsi que monsieur le rapporteur général
les rapporteurs que vous madame Martin
madame Martin excusez-moi monsieur le
ministre madame Martin je vous remercie
de laisser le ministre s'exprimer sinon
je vous rappelle à l'ordre sinon je vous
rappelle à
l'ordre monsieur le ministre merci
madame la Présidente je remercie donc
monsieur Pradal votre travail en tant
que rapporteur et tous ceux qui ont
travaillé sur ce texte ainsi que
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois parce que ce texte a éé adopté
par la commission des lois de
l'Assemblée nationale à une très large
majorité alors que la majorité y est en
majorité relative pourquoi parce que
d'abord vous l'avez dit c'est un texte
qui est soutenu par les Français est-ce
qu'on fait hier une majorité de députés
c'est de se mettre d'accord pour que les
Français n'aient pas de débat c'est de
se mettre d'accord pour que les Français
n'aient pas le texte qu'ils souhaitent
et c'est se mettre d'accord dans une
coalition en effet des contraires sans
majorité alternative pour que les
Français ne connaissent pas des
solutions
contre l'immigration irrégulière et
contre les étrangers délinquants ce
qu'on a fait hier en votant la MO de
Roget on n pas rejeté le texte puisquil
est envoyé en CMP comme l' dit madame la
Première ministre on a rejeté le débat
dans la chambre qui est censé débattre
on a rejeté le débat on a fait perdre du
temps au policiers au gendarmes au
préfet au magistrats et on a
finalement désavouer leur travail qui
peut être contre comme je l'ai dit
hierexam s français pour avoir un titre
de séjour en France qui peut s'opposer
pour l'expulsion d'étrangers délinquants
qui peut refuser d'interdire les mineurs
dans les centres de rétention
administratif monsieur Pradal soyons
fier de notre travail de notre
conviction ne laissons pas ce qu' ont
une petite soupe sur leur petit feu nous
divertir nous sommes là parce que nous
sommes conscients que les Français nous
ont confié la responsabilité celle de
porter nos convictions d'être dur contre
l'immigration irrégulière et d'oublier
les attaques personnelles et et les
attaques politiciennes merci à vous
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
monsieur le
député merci monsieur le ministre le
groupe horizon et apparenté sera fier de
vous soutenir dans cette démarche merci
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur éti
pour le groupe les
républicains merci merci madame la
présidente madame la Première
[Applaudissements]
ministre s'est prononcé
souverainement ce choix mérite le
respect et en aucun cas
l'insulte nous insulter madame la
Première ministre c'est insulter les
Français notre
assemblée notre Assemblée a rappelé une
vérité vous êtes minoritaire dans cette
assemblée
notre Assemblée a
sanctionné a sanctionné dans la forme le
mépris insupportable du ministre de
l'Intérieur qui cède qui cède depuis
hier perdant ses ner à la caricature et
à
l'insulte notre Assemblée a sanctionné
au-delà sur le fond un textead
qui consacr le en même temps politique
symbole de l'impuissance et de
l'immobilisme votre en même temps
migratoire voulait toute à la fois la
régularisation massive de clandestin et
l'expulsion d'autres clandestins cela
est naturellement irresponsable et
incohérent c'est pour cela que nous
n'avons pas que nous n'avons pas
souhaité poursuivre ce faux semblant de
débat c'est pour cela que nous avons
voulu installer le débat sur d'autres
bases ces bases contrairement à ce que
vous avez dit ce débat il va se
poursuivre il va se poursuivre au débat
sur des sur un texte très clair celui
approuvé par les sénateurs c'est ce
texte que nous vous invitons à soutenir
c'est le seul que nous soutiendrons je
vous remercie monsieur le député la
parole est à madame la Première
ministre merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le président Éric
cotti les Français attendent des
réponses face aux enjeux migratoires et
vous le savez monsieur le Président ils
exigent des solutions efficaces pour
éloigner plus rapidement les personnes
en situation irrégulière et mieux
intégrer ce que nous accueillons les
Français approuvent les mesures portées
par notre projet de loi des mesures qui
facilitent l'expulsion des des étrangers
délinquants de ceux qui constituent une
menace pour l'ordre public des mesures
qui donn plus de marge de manœuvre à nos
forces de l'ordre qui simplifie nos
procédures qui renforce les sanctions
contre les
passeurs ces mesures nous en avons
besoin ces mesures attendues par nos
concitoyens c'est mesure enrichies par
le Sénat et la commission des lois de
l'Assemblée nationale sont celles
portées par notre projet de loi et je
veux ici saluer l'engagement du ministre
de l'Intérieur Gérald armanin et lui
dire toute ma
confiance et je veux remercier tous les
parlementaires qui ont choisi de
construire plutôt que de s'opposer par
principe qui ont choisi le débat plutôt
que le coup d'éclat
monsieur le présidentti vous vous
appelez à des débats au Parlement sur
l'immigration et pourtant hier avec
l'anupes et le rassemblement national
vous avez refusé le débat vous avez
refusé le débat mais les défis reste et
les attentes des Français sont intactes
nous avons besoin de solution nous avons
besoin d'un texte rapidement notre
détermination ne faiblit pas comme pour
tous les textes nous cherchons des
compromis
comme pour plus de 50 textes depuis 18
mois nous savons que nous pouvons y
parvenir nous respectons les règles de
la démocratie parlementaire nous avons
décidé nous
avons nous avons décidé de convoquer une
commission mixte paritaire rapidement
pour tenter de trouver un accord sur un
texte un texte qui doit pouvoir trouver
une majorité au Sénat comme à
l'Assemblée nationale en toutes
circonstances la volonté de donner des
réponses efficaces reste notre objectif
la recherche d'accord reste notre
méthode au service de notre pays au
service des Français je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame la Première
ministre la parole est à Monsieur Aran
balanan pour le groupe démocrate merci
madame la
[Applaudissements]
Présidente vendredi dernier une
professeure de françaisillustré son
cours sur les métapor les métamorphoses
d'vid avec la présentation d'un tableau
de guissp César il ne s'agissait donc ni
plus ni moins d'une manière de lier deux
arts la peinture et la littérature
depuis pourtant cette professeur et
l'ensemble de l'équipe éducative ont
demandé à bénéficier de leur droit de
retrait en cause des élèves se sont
insurgés contre des propos ressentis
comme racistes accusation qu'ils ont
pourtant depuis connu comme étant
mensongère trop mal trop tard le mal
était fait il ne s'agit pas d'un simple
fait divhers et je crois que cette cette
situation est l'illustration d'un
problème plus profond dans nos écoles
celle de la remise en question de notre
principe de laïcité monsieur le ministre
ce sont bien vos mots que je fais mien
aujourd'hui à l'école française on ne
conteste pas l'autorité on la respecte à
l'école française on ne conteste pas la
laïcité on la
ce sont des propos que nous devrions
tous
saluer
pardon notre pays héritier des lumières
et de l'universalisme ne peut se laisser
enfermer dans de telles attaques nous
devons défendre nos notre principe de
laïcité qui je le rappelle impose le
respect de toutes les croyances
l'égalité de tous les citoyen devant la
loi sans distinction de religion et la
garantie par la République du du libre
exerci des cultes le principe de la
laïcité est un pilier de notre société
pour nos enfants l'école est un lieu de
son approtissage et ils doivent accepter
d'y construire leur esprit critique mais
ne doivent pas rejeter ce qu'ils
apprennent au nom de leur religion
quelle qu'elle soit réaffirme
réaffirmons ensemble notre soutien à
l'ensemble des professeurs menacés et
remercionsles pour le courage de leur
engagement merci beaucoup monsieur le
député la parole à Gabriel Atal ministre
de la l'éducation nationale et de la
jeunesse merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député
balanan il faut en revenir à l'essentiel
le rôle de l'école française c'est de
former des républicains et notre école
l'école française elle a des racines et
dans ces racines il y a la laïcité il y
a l'égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes il y a l'autorité de l'enseignant
et je le dis monsieur le
député même si certains même si certains
cherchent à provoquer ces racines ou à
déraciner notre école ces racines elles
sont solides elles sont portées chaque
jour par des centaines de milliers
d'enseignants qui forment des
républquain qui démocratisse le savoir
au service de notre pays et de notre
République je le redis ici devant vous
comme je l'ai dit hier aux enseignants
d'ous je me suis rendu au collège
Jacques carartier jamais je n'accepterai
à l'école de la République qu'on refuse
de garder un tableau qu'on se bouche les
oreilles en cours de musique qu'on s'en
prenne à l'autorité d'un
enseignant vous le savez monsieur le
député j'ai placé mon action sous le
saut de l'efficacité moi je ne prends
pas des positions je prends des
décisions et je les fait appliquer c'est
pour cela que sous l'autorité de la
première ministre et du Président j'ai
décidé d'interdire le port de la BA et
du camis à l'école et que j'ai fait
respecter cette
interdiction c'est pour cela
que j'ai décidé de sanctionner les
élèves qui ont contesté le moment
d'hommage à la mémoire de Samuel paatti
et de Dominique Bernard et que ses
élèves ont été
sanctionné c'est pour cela monsieur le
député que j'ai dit dès hier que les
élèves responsables de cette situation à
Issou seraient sanctionné et je vous
annonce que ce matin une procédure
disciplinaire a été ouverte à l'endroit
des trois élèves à l'origine de cette
situation oui monsieur le député c'est
un combat c'est un combat qui est
difficile mais je sais avec cette
majorité que nous gagnerons ce combat
pour l'école de la République et pour
notre
pays merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à madame la
Présidente châelin pour le groupe
écologiste merci madame la présidente
madame la Première ministre les
écologistes sont fiers d'avoir porté une
motion de rejet contre un trexte qui
affaiblissait les droits des étrangers
et reprenait les obsessions identitaires
de l'extrême droite les écologistes sont
fiers d'avoir Poé une motion de rejet
contre uNEX qui voulait restreindre les
titres de séjour pour les étrangers
malades et durcir les conditions
d'accueil pour les étudiants et celles
du regroupement familial un texte pour
lequel votre ministre de l'intérieur
était prêt à tout à faire du pied au
députés du ressemblement national
méthode qu'il connaît bien des députés
d'extrême droite qui ont d'ailleurs
apprécié son ouverture sur la
modification de la Constitution à
promettre hier après-midi dans cette
hémicycle le duissement du texte avec le
retour du délit de séjour irrégulier et
un nouveau recul sur la régularisation
des travailleurs sans papier les
manœuvres n'ont pas suffi votre texte a
été démocratiquement rejeté mais que
dire des méthodes crapuleuses de votre
Ministre de l'Intérieur votre Ministre
de l'Intérieur qui a tenté de marchander
les votes des parlementaires contre des
gendarmeries à comble pour un ministre
qui se dit attaché à la sécurité votre
Ministre de l'Intérieur qui s'est vanté
ici de ficher les députés du groupe LR
qui demandent des régularisation
pourquoi si ce'est pour faire du
chantage madame la Première ministre une
alternative sououffre à vous
accep que ce soit votre Ministre de
l'Intérieur di les méthodes et la lig de
votre gouvernement quel sera votre
choix je vous remercie la parole est à
madame la Première
ministre madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés madame la
Présidente châelin alors j'entends que
vous êtes fier madame la Présidente vous
êtes fier d'avoir refusé le débat sur un
texte très lgement souten
vous êtes fier d'avoir fait voter une
motion grâce au voix de l'extrême droite
faisant passer le sinisme et
l'incohérence avant vos principes vous
êtes fier de priver nos concitoyens d'un
texte qu'ils attendent et dont nous
avons besoin mais vous voyez à votre
place madame la Présidente je ne seraai
pas fière et par cette motion vous
cherchez tout simplement à bloquer le
fonctionnement de nos institutions et en
réalité vous n'avez prouvé qu'une chose
vous avez une majorité de blocage mais
pas une majorité d'action vous avez une
majorité pour empêcher mais pas une
majorité pour gouverner alors madame la
Présidente châelin avec Gérald armanin
et avec mon gouvernement nous nous ne
renoncerons jamais à agir au service des
Français c'est pourquoi malgré vos vos
calculs politiciens malgré vos alliances
contre nature nous continuerons à miser
sur le débat parlementaire et sur la
responsabilité des élus de la nation une
commission mixte parit sera convoqué
nous continuerons à chercher un accord
sur ce texte nous continuerons à
chercher des solutions pour les
Françaises et les Français je remercie
merci beaucoup madame la Première
ministre madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre la majorité
parlementaire a pu compter sur les voies
de l'extrême droite pour près de 50 %
des textes présentés par votre
gouvernement est-ce que vous avez jeté
la loi sur les GI la lie voilà la vérité
c'est vrai les chiffres sonts deè le
jour où nous ser pouvoir nous vous
monons notre action on fera le droit de
vote des étrangers on défendra laame on
défendra l'hébergement d'urgence
nousissons vous aviez le choix madame la
Première ministre entre le retrait du
texte ou le déshonneur il n aura pas de
texte et vous aurez le
déshonneur je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Benjamin saintu pour le
groupe
merci madame la Présidente je m'excuse
par avance ma question ne traitera pas
de la problématique migratoire parce que
en France il y a d'autres priorités la
priorité numéro une des Français c'est
la question du pouvoir d'achat partout
en France dans le Nord dans le sud à
l'est à l'ouest que vous soyez
travailleurs salariés retraités
étudiants elle reste le problè la
problématique majeure aujourd'hui au nom
du groupe lot je veux interroger le
gouvernement pour connaître sa position
je veux interroger le ministre du soft
lui parler de la France qui travaille et
qui ne s'en sort plus monsieur le
ministre les chiffres récents ont été
annoncés 17 % des travailleurs dans ce
pays sont des smicars jamais ce chiffre
n'a été si important et au-delà de ces
17 % les travailleurs pauvres sont de
plus en plus nombreux rattrapés par un
SMIC qui lui évolue et eux qui se voient
tasser par leur bas par le bas dans leur
salaire vous avez à notre demande mis
place une conférence sociale sur les
salaires mais vous avez limité la
discussion à ce stade aux 39 branches
qui pratiquent des minimas en dessous du
SMIC ma question est simple si cette
mesure va dans le bon sens elle est
évidemment très loin de ce nous avons
besoin en terme de réponse pour le
pouvoir d'achat des travailleurs
quellees mesures concrète rapide urgente
le gouvernement compte-il mettre en
place pour permettre au bas salairire
d'enfin progresser et ainsi rendre de la
fierté et de la dignité à ceux qui
veulent simplement vivre de leur
travail je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier du sopt ministre du
Travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député sainthuille m'
interterroger sur la question du pouvoir
d'achat et particulièrement l'évolution
des salaires et plus particulièrement
encore des bas salaires autour du SMIC
ou un peu supérieur au SMIC vous avez
raison d'abord de rappeler que nous
avons un mécanisme d'indexation du SMIC
qui a permis depuis le 1er janvier 2021
de voir le SMIC augmenter 7 fois donct
quatre pour faire face à l'inflation
c'est une augmentation au total de 13,5
% qui a protégé le pouvoir d'achat des
salariés les plus modestes et qui
explique très largement le chiffre de 17
% de salariés os SMIC au 1er janvier
2023 il y a déjà quelques mois puisque
dès lors que le SMIC augmente rapidement
il est assez logique d'une certaine
manière que les plus basses rémunération
soit rattrapé nous ne devons pas laisser
s'installer cette situation c'est la
raison pour laquelle à l'occasion de la
conférence salariale que la conférence
sociale pardon que nous avons organisé
avec madame la Première ministre nous
avons indiqué que nous souhtions ouvrir
deux chantiers premier chantier sur la
question des classifications c'est
évidemment un peu technique mais ça
relève du du dialogue de branchees et de
la capacité qu'ont les branches
professionnelles à prévoir des
gradations salariales en fonction de
l'ancienneté et des compétences pour
permettre des carrières qui soient
marquées par des progressions salariales
et non pas une stagnation au début de la
carrière ça c'est la première chose la
deuxième chose c'est que nous devons
faire attention à ce que les branches
professionnel qui ont en charge la
discussion et la négociation sociale
autour de la question des salaires parce
que vous le savez c'est l'état par la
loi qui détermine le niveau du SMIC mais
ce sont les partenaires sociaux qui
fixent les les niveaux conventionnels et
je crois que nous partageons cet intérêt
de laisser au dialogue social la
détermination du niveau des
rémunérations nous devons faire en sorte
que les branches soient plus actives
j'ai réuni hier le comité de suivi des
négociations salariales je reçois dans
les 15 jours qui viennent et dès demain
les branches qui sont les plus en retard
en matière de mise en conformité nous
mettons en œuvre tous les les outils
dont nous disposons y compris ceux
prévus par la loi de juillet 2022
autorisant des restructurations de
branche pour les celles qui ne jouent
pas le jeu et nous envisageons avec la
première ministre des textes dès 2024
pour sanctionner les branches qui ne se
seraient pas mises en conformité merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre monsieur
le
député merci pour votre réponse monsieur
le ministre mais reconnaissons que ça
n'est pas suffisant je vous propose
quelque chose de simple est-ce qu'on
pourrait ici dans cette belle maison
étudier l'hypothèse de supprimer les
cotisations salariales chez les bas
salaires de les faire
sur les haut revenus ça rendrait du cash
immédiatement au français qui
travaillent et qui n'arrivent pas à
arrondir les fins de mois ce serait
facile de le faire ce serait de la
justice fiscale et sociale on ferait
peser sur les plus hauts salaires les
efforts il serait temps de répartir
enfin les richesses je vous remerci
merci
beaucoup la parole est à Madame l Miller
pour le groupe
Renaissance
merciés ministre de l'Intérieur et des
outremèes mes chers collègues hier un
peu avant pardon hier un peu avant 18h
une sorte de conjuration des aigris a
donc décidé contre la vie d'une majorité
des Français d'empêcher tout débat sur
un des plus grands défis de notre siècle
l'immigration hier 270 parlementaires
ont donc décidé tout bonnement de
censurer le
Parlement hier alors même que vous
passez votre temps à nous donner des
leçons de démocratie vous avez
per des
frçisê la muselière que vous vous
êtesmême accroché et j à la poubelleos
1940 amendements déposé sur ce texte
formidable cooup médiatique formidable
coup médiatique et après j'entends que
le en même temps serait un échec mais
mes chers collègues vous nous rappelez
sans cesse à la composition éclétique de
notre assemblée donc oui par définition
il nous faut aboutir à des compromis
tous nos voisins européens sont assez
responsables pour le faire vous a fait
montrer hier que vous n'étiez pas
capable et que vous préférez la
paralysie à l'action responsable
monsieur le ministre les Français sont
donc privés momentanément de débat sur
un texte qu'ils appellent pourtant
massivement de leur vœux monsieur le
ministre nous avons besoin de ce texte
nous avons besoin d'expulser plus
facilement les désincants étrangers qui
représentent une menace pour nos
concitoyens nous avons besoin de cette
loi pour retirer leur titre de ses jours
à ceux qui adhèrent à l'islam radical
nous avons besoin de simplifier
drastiquement les procédures en
inspirant du rapport du sénateur buffet
nous avons besoin d'améliorer
l'intégration en conditionnant les
titres de séjour longue durée à un
examen de français nous policiers nos
gendarmes ont besoin d'inspecter les
véhicules aux frontières si l'on veut
lutter contre l'immigration clandestine
nous avons besoin de ce texte pour armer
notre justice contre les basseurs et les
marchands de sommeil nous avons besoin
de ce texte si l'on veut supprimer la
présence des mineurs dans les centrre de
rétention administrative monsieur le
ministre un de vos illustres
prédécesseurs disait ne craignez jamais
de vous faire des ennemis nous en avonsz
pas collègues la parole est à Monsieur
géralde Darmanin ministre de l'Intérieur
et des
outresemires
[Musique]
pardon madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la député
Miller ce qui est certain c'est que ce
sont les
policiers les
gendarmes vous les avez déjà privé de
moyens c'est peut-être pas la peine de
les mépriser en
public les policiers les gendarmes les
magistrats les agents de préfecture qui
ne sont pas dans le petit jeu de la boue
politicienne avec le RN qui vote avec la
nupes et laanupes qui vote avec le RN
ils sont tous les jours sur terrain mais
je pense au maire de
Menton je pense au maire de Menton qui
réclame à des moyens supplémentaires que
prévoyait le projet de loi avec
notamment l'inspection vous le savez
l'inspection des véhicules qui
traversent sa frontière qu'aujourd'hui
les policiers ne peuvent pas regarder
s'il n a pas ce projet de loi je pense
au maire de Briançon qui tous les jours
courageusement lutte contre
l'immigration irrégulière contre les
passeurs et qui réclame le fait que les
policiers puissent demander co pour
prendre l'identité des personnes je
pense à la courageuse mère de Calais et
à toute la côte d'Opal qui réclame
depuis longtemps monsieur le gardessau
que ce soit un crime pour les passeurs
et pas un
délit je pense à tous ces policiers ces
gendarmes ces yeux locaux et ces
magistrats qui ont dû regarder et
pleurer l'Assemblée nationale qui est
censé discuter amender et adopt refuser
d'accomplir son rôle alors oui nous
allons ue à travailler malgré les embûes
parce que nous regardons l'intérêt
général et oui nous avons un texte ferme
et fort et c'est sans doute Madame M
pour ça qui n'a pas voulu être discuté
parce qu'il est plus facile de faire des
traacks sur des marchés que de faire la
loi pour la
République je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Madame
clémentinetin pour la France
insoumise madame la ministre des di et
des dizaines de milliers de Palestiniens
ont été tués par l'armée israélienne à
Gaza sans compter les meurtres perpétrés
par les colons de six Jordanie sans
compter les effets du blocus avec le
manque d'eau potable d'électricité de
soins et sans compter encore les 86
journalistes assassinés depuis les 1200
civiles israéliens attrocement massacrés
par le Hamas le 7 octobre le
gouvernement d'extrême droite de
netaniaahou précipite la région dans une
boucherie sans nom au mépris du droit
international hier Joseph Borel leader
de la diplomatie de l'Union européenne
alerta sur la situation à Gaza la
qualifiant
d'apocalyptique il faut dire que les
bombardements s'appuient désormais sur
l'intelligence artificielle qui n'est
jamais que la créature de son maître
appliquant la consigne morbide de
n'avoir aucune limite en terme de
victime collatéral entendez évidemment
d'assassinat de civil ce que mes chers
collègues doit
cesser le vetto posé vendredi à l'ONU
sur une résolution pour un cess le feu
largement plébiscité montre combien les
États-Unis protègent en toute circonstan
Israël et combien le fonctionnement de
cette organisation internationale
nécessite aussi d'être réformé pour
autant aujourd'hui l'Assemblée générale
de l'ONU exhortera une nouvelle fois la
communauté internationale à agir en
vertu de la responsabilité de
protéger madame la ministre quelle sera
la position de la France allez-vous
sortir des zigzags pour que la parole de
la France soit forte cohérente
déterminée que nous en finissions avec
ce décomte des morts civiles quel qu'ell
soit allez-vous enfin mobiliser
l'ensemble de notre diplomatie au
service du cesser le feu à Gaza quant à
nous mes chers collègues nous marcherons
encore dimanche
la parole est à Madame Catherine Colona
monsieur Habib s'il vous plaît la parole
est à Madame Catherine Colona ministre
de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères monsieur Habib s'il vous
plaît madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la député
ha depuis le début de la guerre
déclenchée par le Hamas le 7
octobre la France n'a cessé de chercher
à rassembler la communauté
internationale autour de trois principes
clairs le premier c'est le rejet du
terrorisme toujours et la condamnation
du Hamas organisation terroriste à ma
demande avec l'Allemagne et l'Italie
l'Union européenne examine un nouveau
régime de sanction contre ce groupe
terroriste le deuxième évidemment c'est
la libération de tous les otages
dont nos qure compatriotes encore
disparus à Gaza et nous pensons tous à
eux le trisème c'est la protection des
populations civiles obligation morale
autant qu'obligation juridique ça
signifie apporter de l'aide en quantité
suffisante aux populations civil de Gaza
qui vivent une tragédie oui et ça
signifie aussi obtenir une pause
humanitaire durable menant à un cesser
le feu sur ces bases la France a voté
successivement les projets de résolution
présentés au Conseil de sécurité par le
Brésil les États-Unis
d'Amérique les Émirats arabes unis
textes qui n'ont pas pu aboutir du fait
de V mais d'autres textes ont abouti au
Conseil de sécurité à l'assemblée
générale et oui en effet à l'Assemblée
Générale aujourd'hui un autre projet de
résolution sera votée avec la voix de la
France et à chaque fois notre pays à
uvrer pour dégager des solutions il
continuera d' vrer pour que la
communauté internationale se rassemble
autour des questions humanitaire de
sécurité et inf d'une solution politique
la seule qui amènera la paix je vous
remercie je vous remercie madame la
ministre la parole est à Madame anneblin
pour les
républicains merci Madame la présid Mame
la prière
ministre admirable engagés généreusement
dans nos territoires ils assurent cette
mission de service public qui garantit
sécurité et protection à nos concitoyens
et c'est parce qu'il s'engage sans
compter que le Parlement a adopté il y a
quelques mois des dispositions pour
reconnaître leur
volontariat alors il y a quelques
semaines monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur annoncait que le décret
portant bonification de leur retraite
serait publié d'ici la fin du mois alors
qu'elle ne fut pas ma surprise lorsque
durant les sains barbes organisé partout
dans nos casernes oui nous avons
découvert qu'en vérité et oui le
gouvernement préparait un décret pour le
moins réducteur et oui nous avons appris
que votre gouvernement envisageait de
reconnaître l'engagement des seuls
sapeurs pompiers volontaires ayant des
carrières
achurées en excluant les ceux qui
avaient une carrière professionnelle en
parallèle de leur engagement citoyen
comment
comment pouvez-vous sacrifier ceux qui
se donnent avec générosité parfois au
péril de leur vie nos sapeurs pompiers
volontaires sont un maillon essentiel de
nos secours ils sont essentiels dans nos
territoires ruraux ils agissent chaque
jour avec un engagement sans faille avec
le soutien de leur famille reconnaître
valoriser leur engagement c'était la
volonté du législateur alors madame la
Première ministre ce décret Bafou la
volonté du peuple affirmé dans cet
hémicycle il trompe nos sa peeur pompier
alors pouvez-vous nous garantir ici très
solennellement que votre gouvernement
fera tout pour faire respecter
struulusement la volonté du législateur
et que tous tous les sapeurs pomp
volontaires de France seront reconnus à
leur juste
valeur je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur géralde Darmanin ministre de
l'Intérieur et des outres
mèes madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs députés madame la députée Blin
je vous remercie de remarquer que c'est
la majorité actuelle qui en effet va
reconnaître c'est la majorité actuel qui
en effet va reconnaître par un décret
par un décret par un décret qui est
encore au Conseil d'État et que vous
commente et qui n'est même pas encore
publié qui n'est même pas encore publié
et qui va en effet reconnaître
l'engagement courageux de nos sapeurs
pompiers volontaires et qui va en effet
appliquer la loi strictement comme il
fait sur tous les amendements qui aur
été proposés par tous les groupes
lorsque la loi matras a été adoptée
lorsque le PLFSS aura soutenu un certain
nombre de démarche qui sont
transpartisans je l'ai moême dit au
députés CERI avant qu'il ne quitte
l'Assemblée nationale et vous pourrez
compter sur moi en tant que ministre
pour appliquer strictement la loi voulue
par les parlementaires et respecter bien
évidemment l'engagement de sapport
pompier je vous remercie madame Blin
merci Monsieur le Ministre effectivement
la volonté du législateur c'est de
couvrir l'ensemble des sapeurs pompiers
volontaires de ce pays il n'est pas
question que seul 10 % des sapeurs
pompiers volontaires soi destinataire de
ce de ce bénéfice de retraite et de
bonification merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre nous l'entendons bien Madame la
Députée et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que
nous y travaillons peut-être qu'il
aurait été plus loisible d'attendre le
décret sorti par le gouvernement avant
de le commenter ou peut-être ou ou
peut-être ou peut-être peut-être
considérez-vous alors si cela correspond
exactement à l'engagement que nous avons
eu c'est de la majorité que ça sans
précédent et que vous le devrait au
président de la République j'espère que
vous poserez une question à ce moment-là
je vous remerci monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Madame Caroline Parmentier
pour le merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à la ministre de la
Culture madame la ministre lors d'une
conférence de presse qui aurait pu
passer inaperçu vous avez lancé le
programme la relève en partenariat avec
sciencep visant à Renou les postes de
direction du monde de la culture en plus
de l'origine géographique et sociale
vous proposez au nom de la diversité de
prendre notamment en compte je cite le
critère de la couleur de peau dans ce
recrutement ce que vous proposez là
madame la ministre c'est de la
discrimination sur la base d'un critère
ethnique c'est du racisme le racisme est
une infraction à la loi
française pire qu'un et pire une insulte
à nos valeurs jusqu'à présent au nom de
l'article 6 de la Déclaration des droits
de l'homme qui dispose que tous les
citoyens sont également
admissibles à toute dignité places et
emplois public selon leur capacité et
sans autres distinction que celle de
leurs vertus et de leurs talents la
France s'était refusé à suivre la voie
du racialisme américain en France seule
la compétence justifie une nomination et
constitue le seul critère légitime et
légal pour départager des candidats à
une fonction administrative et
culturelle madame la ministre
pouvez-vous nous expliquer quel est le
sens de cette proposition et ce qu'elle
signifie est-ce que cela veut dire qu'il
y a trop de blanc parmi les dirigeants
de la culture après vos sorties contre
C8 et C news à qui vous vouliez retirer
leur fréquence après vos brevets de
valeurs républicaines aux journaux après
votre réaction très gênée sur la FP et
le Hamas bravo après Miriam Cann après
Bastien vivess et maintenant la
racialisation des recrutements dans la
culture où voulez-vous très exactement
nous emmener et où voulez-vous emmener
la culture
française je vous remercie la parole est
à Madame Rima
abdoumak ministre de la
Culture madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Parmentier ce n'est pas la première fois
que votre groupe s'illustre en
fabrication de fake news encore une fois
vous démontrez que vous n'avez aucune
considération pour la réalité si vous
aviez pris le temps de regarder la
conférence de presse que vous mentionnez
du lancement de cette initiative qui
s'appelle la rela vous aurez pu
constater que tout ce que vous dites est
faux je n'ai pas parlé de critères j'ai
précisé plusieurs fois que j'entendais
diversité au sens diversité sociale et
géographique c'est même le titre du
programme la relève c'est une initiative
pour accélérer l'égalité des chances
pour former un jeune par département à
intégrer les métiers de la culture
élargir notre vivier de recrutement pour
les postes à responsabilité mais
pourquoi la diversité vous fait
peur
pourquoi qu'est-ce qui vous fait
peur qu'est-ce qui vous fait peur cette
diversité c'est une richesse pour la
France c'est une chance pour l'avenir de
nos institutions culturelles mais
au-delà des attaques personnelles parce
que je commence à être un petit peu
habitué la plus grande fake news
aujourd'hui c'est quoi la plus grande
manipulation aujourd'hui 12 décembre
c'est quoi c'est que vous le
rassemblement national vous voulez nous
faire croire que vous êtes devenu le
parti à l'avant-garde de la lutte contre
les discriminations et la lutte contre
le racisme vous non mais
sérieusement vous le parti de la
stigmatisation permanente vous qui
n'avez que l'obsession identitaire à la
bouche vous qui traitez un député de
racaille et qui hurlez à un autre de
retourner en Afrique
vous et vos frères d'armes de reconquête
qui veulent changer les prénoms de ceux
qui ont un nom comme le mien qui ont une
consonance étrangère c'est ça qui qui
vous fait peur c'est cette diversité
c'est ça la grande manipulation c'est
au-delà du cynisme c'est au-delà de
l'hypocrisie mais les Français ne seront
pas
d je vous remercie madame la ministre
madame
parmentier ministre je note votre
fébrilité j'ai regardé votre conférence
de presse et vous avez parlé de couleur
de peau nous n'avons pas peur de la
diversité
merci je vous remercie la parole est à
monsieur Guillaume Gouffier Vallante
pour le groupe
Renaissance merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse aux gardes des sa
ministres de la Justice monsieur le
ministre il y a quelques semaines ma
collègue Marie piierrexin interroger
madame la Première ministre sur le
projet de loi constitutionnel visant à
garantir pleinement la liberté de
recours àivg à cette occasion le
gouvernement indiquait que ce texte
serait présenté en Conseil des ministres
avant la fin de l'année c'est désormais
chose faite et je tiens au nom de notre
groupe à vous féliciter pour le respect
de ce calendrier et cet engagement
tellement
essentiel à ce titre permettez-moi de
rappeler chers collègues pourquoi ce
texte est majeur à l'heure où certains
tentent d'en minimiser malheureusement
la porté dans notre pays mais aussi en
Europe et dans le monde disons-le
clairement les forces réactionnaire qui
ont pour objectif de remettre en cause
l'avortement son accès pour toutes les
femmes son fondement même en tant que
droit ou liberté fondamental grandissent
ces mouvements antichoix sont organisés
financés intégrés ils agissent au cœur
de nos démocraties ils s'expriment même
au sein de certains partis politiques y
compris dans cet hémicycle à travers le
rassemblement national prenons garde ils
ne nous le diront jamais comme tel ne le
brandiront pas au moment des élections
mais une fois au pouvoir ces partis
conservateurs et extrémistes feront tout
pour dévo
entrav presque aniler l'avortement sa
liberté la plus fondamentale et son
accès le plus essentiel alors dans ce
cadre qui pourrait considérer que tout
moyen visant à le garantir ne serait pas
utile la constitutionnalisation de l'IVG
est une avancé considérable historique
même notre pays celui des libertés des
lumières celui de Simon veille de Gisel
aléi du Manifeste des 343 sera le
premier au monde à inscrire cette
liberté fondamentale dans sa
constitution et au-delà en verrait un
message clair réunique au monde entier
monsieur le ministre à l'initiative des
parlementaires dont notre ancienne
présidente Aurore berger une proposition
de loi constitutionnelle avait été voté
à l'Assemblée nationale puis en des
termes différents au Sénat le
Gouvernement présente désormais une
troisème voix d'écriture pourriez-vous à
cet égard nous préciser les la
philosophie de cette écriture et les
éléments de calendrier pour l'adoption
la discussion et l'adoption de ce texte
je vous remercie merci beaucoup la
parole est à monsieur Éric Dupont
Moretti garde d' saau et ministre de la
Justice merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames Messieurs les Députés monsieur
le député Gouffier Valente le projet de
loi
constitutionnelle relatif à la liberté
de recourir à l'interruption volontaire
de grossesse a été présenté ce matin
même en conseil des ministres ce projet
de loi est un engagement fort du
président de la République et de
l'ensemble du gouvernement mais il est
aussi le résultat de l'engagement total
du Parlement et de l'Assemblée nationale
je veux ici saluer cette mobilisation la
vôtre monsieur le député celle de tous
les députés de la majorité et de
l'opposition qui ont rendu possible
cette nouvelle étape mais une révision
constitutionnelle nécessite un vote
identique à l'Assemblée et au Sénat qui
ont pour l'instant adopté vous le savez
deux versions différentes l'écriture
retenue fait converger les deux versions
la voici la loi détermine les conditions
dans lesquelles s'exerce la liberté
garantie à la femme d'avoir recours à
une interruption volontaire de grossesse
cette écriture issue du Conseil d'État
permet de respecter le renvoi à la loi
voulu par les deux
assemblées tout en inscrivant dans la
Constitution que la liberté d'avoir
recours à l'IVG c'était le souit du
Sénat serait garanti c'était le souhait
de votre assemblée il s'agit là d'une
occasion
historique que vous avez que nous avons
collectivement rendu possible il nous
faut désormais aller au bout et si la
route est encore longue les débats ce
mot-l prend aujourd'hui un sens
particulier que nous aurons sans aucun
doute seront riches mais ne perdons pas
notre objectif commun nul je dis bien
nul ne doit pouvoir retirer aux femmes
le droit de disposer de votre corps je
serai le 16 janvier en commission merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre la parole
est à Madame Elsa fossillon pour le
groupe
GDR merci madame la Présidente hier les
députés d'opposition ont adopté la
motion de rejet du texte immigration que
vous portez depuis 1 an notre groupe l'a
voté en
responsabilité résolument opposé à ce
texte qui allait multiplier les
souffrances des exilés et à fabriquer
plus de précarité et de misère votez
aussi pour mettre fin aux propos
racistes et xénophobes tenus au sein
même de notre Parlement votez enfin
parce que les débats autour de ce texte
ne font que fracturer un peu plus notre
pays il n'y a pas de France comme le
prétendent les promoteurs du choc de
civilisation mais bien un peuple en
quête d'unité autour de
l'égalité
notre pays souffre d'une crise de
l'accueil c'est vrai pour les exiler
mais c'est aussi vrai dans nos crèches
et nos épades dans nos écoles et nos
hôpitaux dans nos commissariats et nos
préfectures et les étrangers n'en sont
pas responsables en revanche vos choix
politiques qui visent à préserver les
intérêts des plus riches oui elles le
sont l'explication par le Bou émissaire
est depuis toujours l'ossature de
l'extrême droite les soi-disant
républicain lui ont emboîé le pas mais
c'est bien un président de la République
élu contre l'extrême droite qui a assumé
dans ce contexte de présenter une une 1è
loi sur l'immigration valitant des
thèses aussi répugnantes qu'un fondé tes
que l'appel d'air on ne combat pas les
idées d'extrême droite en les
légitimant vous avez vous avez hier
essuyé une lourde défaite elle n'est
finalement que la réalité qui devrait
s'imposer à vous depuis 1 an vous n'avez
pas de majorité poursuivre l'examen de
ce texte en CMP serait un violent coup
de force en plus d'un péché d'orgueil
franchement après 20493 vous n'avez
aucune leçon à donner au Parlement en
matière de débat car
démocratie en réalité en démocratie le
rejet d'hier s'impose à vous alors cessz
de fracturer le
pays merci beaucoup ma ch
collèg la parole est à
monie l'intérieur et des autres
m madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les député madame la députée
Fillon vous connaissez bien ce texte
vous l'avez suivi en tant que
commissaire au loi
assidument et vous avez finalement
choisi de voter une Mo de Roger avec le
rassemblement national sur un texte qui
prévoyait l'interdiction de la présence
des mineurs dans les centre de rétention
administratif ce que jamais la gauche
n'a fait madame la députée même
en responsabilité des enfants dans les
centres de rétention administratif dans
les lieux de rétention
administratif nous avons choisi nous en
lien d'ailleurs avec la gauche du Sénat
nous avons choisi nous en lien avec vous
puisque c'est en commission des loi que
nous avons dit que c'était à partir de
moins de 18 ans et dès la promulgation
des lois de pouvoir faire une avancée
que tout le monde réclamait mais que
jamais ne faisait au pouvoir et vous
avez voté avec Madame Le Pen une motion
de rejet vous avez voté avec Madame Le
Pen pour mettre fin à la régularisation
de travailleurs qui en effet ne demande
rien d'autre que de vivre dans la
République vous avez voté avec Madame Le
Pen madame fossillon pour les cours
gratuits pour les étrangers vous avez
même voté avec Madame Le Pen pour éviter
que les marchands de sommeil soit
combattu contre vos propres avancées
communistes du Sénat madame fossillon
vous avez préféré manifestement le petit
coup politique et demain vous savez ce
que vous aurez bah vous aurez évidemment
un texte qui ne correspondra pas
discussion qu'on aurait pu avoir avec
vous puisquon a montré que nous étions
ouverts vous avez choisi vos intérêts
politiqu politicien à tous ces personnes
qui étai jusqu'à présent dans les
centres de rétention administratif mais
ça changera pas grandchose parce que
depuis que je suis ministre je le fais
il n'y a plus de mur dans C de rétention
ce que vous n'avez jamais fait
responsabilité je vous remercie monsieur
le ministre la parole est à Monsieur
groupe
Renaissance mer Mame la présid mination
et de la jeunesse l'école est le socle
de notre société elle accompagne nos
enfants sur le chemin de la citoyenneté
à l'heure où les valeurs républicaines
sont menacées attaqué l'uniforme est
l'une des réponses au besoins de
symboles commun grâce auquel notre
jeunesse apprend à faire nation la tenue
unique est l'expression du principe
selon lequel chacun indépendamment de
son origine sociale de sa couleur de
peau de sa religion ou de son sexuelle
et dépositaire des mêmes droits et des
mêmes devoirs honorant ainsi la promesse
républicaine qu'une place soit accordée
à tous à l'école comme au sein de notre
communauté nationale si l'uniforme n'est
pas la solution miracle à toutes les
difficultés auxquelles l'école est
confrontée partout où il existe déjà le
constat est identique il participe à la
lutte contre le harcèlement scolaire il
contribue à un sentiment d'appartenance
et amène chaque élève à orueillir d'une
culture valorisée commune et partagée en
Nouvelle-Calédonie la province Sud a
généralisé la tenue scolaire commune il
y a 7 ans et les retours sont plus que
positifs 92 % des parents sont
satisfaits et là où le vêtement était un
marqueur différenciant l'uniforme a
contribué à amoindrir la manifestation
des inégalités sociales pour ces raisons
monsieur le ministre nous nous
réjouissons de votre prise de position
audacieuse sur ce sujet qui a trop
longtemps été caricaturé et marginalisé
comme nous l'avons fait à l'annonce de
la mesure que vous avez prise pour
interdire la BAA à l'école nous
soutenons aujourd'hui la large
expérimentation que vous préconisez par
ailleurs nous saluons votre volonté
exprimée lors de vos récentes
déclarations de ne pas faire porter le
coût de cette expérimentation sur les
familles monsieur le ministre une
question pouvez-vous nous en dire
davantage sur les modalités pratiques de
la mise en place de cette
expérimentation je vous remercie je vous
remercie mon cher collègue la parole est
à Monsieur Gabriel ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la
jeunesse merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député Adrien Gomi il est en
France des débats qui durent
éternellement qui déclench des
discussions parfois interminables dans
les familles politiques dans les
familles tout courts et je suis sûr
qu'il en sera de même dans les soirées
des fêtes encore cette année la question
du port de l'uniforme à l'école fait
partie de ces débats j'y vois surtout
l'attachement des Français à leur école
et le souhait très largement partagé
chez les Français de toujours chercher
les solutions qui permettent au climat
scolaire de s'améliorer et au niveau de
nos élèves de s'élever il y a donc des
débats réguliers sur la question de
savoir si l'uniforme pourrait être utile
à l'apaisement du climat scolaire et à
l'élévation du niveau général à l'école
vous le savez moi j'ai toujours une
obsession c'est de trancher de décider
et pour ça je pense qu'il faut faire
progresser le débat et c'est la raison
pour laquelle j'ai eu l'occasion de le
dire je suis favorable à ce qu'il y ait
une expérimentation de grande ampleur
sur la question du port de l'uniforme à
l'école française je pense que ça
permettra de mesurer si oui ou non il y
a un apport réel s'agissant du climat
scolaire et l'élévation du niveau et que
la meilleure manière de faire progresser
un débat qui n'en finit pas depuis des
années ou des décennies c'est de tester
les choses j'ai vu et je m'en réjouis
qu'un certain nombre de collectivités
locales de toute couleur politique
confondu et j'insiste sur ce point de
toute couleurs politique confondu ont
d'ors et déjà manifesté leur intérêt
pour la participation à cette
expérimentation je m'en réjouis ça va
nous permettre de faire progresser le
débat monsieur le député nous aurons
l'occasion d'annoncer dans les prochains
jours les prochaines semaines
prochainement les conditions et le cadre
de cette expérimentation mais vous le
voyez notre détermination réelle avec le
président de la République et la
première ministre à pouvoir faire
progresser ce débat pour prendre
toujours les décisions à travers une
boussole élever le niveau de nos élèves
et garantir un climat scolaire serein je
suis ravi que la majorité nous
accompagne dans cet objectif je vous
remercie monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur Alexis
Jolly pour le rassemblement
national merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre de l'Éducation
nationale et de la jeunesse jeudi
dernier dans un collège des Yvelines la
présentation en classe d'un chefdœuvre
de la Renaissance illustrant une scène
inspirée de la mythologie grecque s'est
transformé en calvaire pour une
professeur insulté menacé traité de
raciste et d'islamophobe par les élèves
et par les enfants par les parents tous
les jours les Français sont confrontés à
la montée de ces revendications
islamistes qui confrontent avec violence
notre civilisation et notre
histoire monsieur le ministre cette
frénésieconoclaste et ce rejet des
expressions artistiques les plus
sublimes n'ont pas leur place dans une
France qui est la mère des arts dans un
récent sondage
diolipope 78 % des musulmans qui vivent
dans notre notre pays disent considérer
la laïcité comme discriminatoire envers
l'Islam alors non seulement la laïcité
s'est construite non pas contre l'islam
mais contre l'Église mais c'est en plus
du fait de ce changement de socle
civilisationnel que l'immigration issue
des pays musulm a été facilité dans
notre pays depuis des décennies tous les
gouvernements dont vous êtes la
continuité ont échoué dans leur
politique d'intégration et dans le
maintien de l'unité de la société
française vous êtes les organisateurs de
cette catastrophe qui frappe notre pays
et qui sera le grand défi des années à
venir les Français savent qu'ils ne
peuvent pas compter sur vous pour les
défendre de son côté le rassemblement
national fera du redressement de la
France et de ses valeurs l'alpha et
l'oméga de son projet de redressement du
pays à l'instar de la proposition de loi
de Marine Le Pen qui vise à bannir
purement et simplement l'islamisme dans
toutes les sphères de la société
monsieur le ministre la politique menée
par votre gouvernement met en péril
l'avenir de la France alors êtes-vous
prêt à prendre cette grave question au
sérieux et allez-vous enfin frapper très
fort réellement et non pas que
symboliquement cette islamisme qui
menace notre
pays je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Gabriel hatal ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la
jeunesse merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député jolie j'ai eu
l'occasion de répondre tout à l'heure à
une question d'Erwan balanan portant sur
le même sujet et de réaffirmer la
détermination qui est la mienne oui il y
a des ingérences il y a du séparatisme
islamiste dans notre pays et je
considère que ma responsabilité de
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse c'est de faire en sorte que
l'école reste toujours un rempart face à
ces coups de bouttoir dans la République
là-dessus je suis très clair mais
monsieur le député vous me pardonnerez
j'espère de considérer à chaque fois que
je vous entends vous exprimer sur ce
sujet qu'il y a beaucoup d'instruments
entalisation et peu de détermination je
le dis preuve en est preuve en est dans
votre question dans votre question de 2
minutes vous n'avez pas eu un seul mot
pour rappeler l'autorité des enseignants
et soutenir les enseignants qui sont en
première ligne face à ces difficultés
pas un mot monsieur le député et moi je
le dis j'ai de la mémoire à chaque fois
que nous fermons un lieu séparatiste
dans notre pays j'ai en mémoire le fait
que votre présidente de groupe avait
refusé de voter la loi qui nous permet
de fermer ses
établissements chaque fois que nous
prenons descision contre le séparatisme
à l'école j'ai en mémoire que votre
présidente de groupe n'avait pas voulu
voter la loi sur l'école de 2019 qui
nous donne les outils pour le faire j'ai
en mémoire à chaque fois que je me
réjouis chaque jour qu'il n'y ait plus
d'Aba à l'école de la République que
deux députés de votre groupe avaient
tenté de s'incruster dans un
établissement et avait perturbé le
travail du proviseur à la rentrée pour
faire interdire la BAA dans cet
établissement ce qui avait été dénoncé
par les équipes ne vous en déplaise ne
vous en déplaise derrière les propos
desestades derrière les hurlements avec
la meut il y a ceux qui agissent et
cette majorité elle agit cette première
ministre elle agit elle continuera à
agir contre le séparatisme et pour
l'école de la République nous n'agissons
pas grâce à vous nous agissons malgré
vous je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur Alexis
Corbière pour le couple la France
insoumise madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre de l'Éducation nationale je
souhaite vous interroger sur l'avenir de
600 27000 élèves soit près de 30% d'une
classe d'âge sur l'avenir de 2080
établissement soit 56 % de nos lycé je
parle ici de l'enseignement
professionnel qui accueille cette
jeunesse issue des milieux populaires au
parents généralement ouvriers employés
l'enseignement professionnel est
aujourd'hui mobilisé pour s'opposer à
vos projet et nous saluons cette
mobilisation je rés vre jet par un fait
choquant parlant vous voulez supprimer
170 heur d'enseignement en 3 ans pour
nos élèves de Bac Professionnel 170 he
de moins en 2009 déjà le bac
professionnel est passé de 4 à 3 ans à
cause de vous en 2018 monsieur blanqueer
a supprimé 30 % d'enseignement général
et professionnel et vous continuez ce
saccage vous les heures volé par plus de
stage en entreprise alors que nos élèves
il passent déjà de nombreuses semaines
vous supprimez des heures d'enseignement
de professeurs qualifiés en entretenant
le myth de l'entreprise formatrice en
elle-même qui remplace l'apport
pédagogique du professeur toute
l'histoire de la République est un long
travail pour sortir l'enseignement des
mains d'intérêts privés religieux ou
patronaux pour le confier à l'école
publique garante de l'intérêt général
vous faites l'effet inverse les futurs
trava travilleur et travailleuses ont
besoin d'une qualification exigeante
émancipatrice de diplômes reconnus et de
professeurs qui les transmettent ainsi
ils préserveront leur puissance et leur
indépendance alors Monsieur le Ministre
retirez cette réforme rendez les heures
aux élèves de l'enseignement
professionnel je vous remercie la parole
est à madame Carole grandjan ministre
délégué chargé de l'enseignement et de
la formation
professionnelle merci madame la
Présidente Mame Mames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député corbierre
effectivement c'est la ministre en
charge de l'enseignement professionnel
et de la formation professionnelle qui
vous répond peut-être monsieur corbierre
pensez-vous que ces jeunes ont confiance
sont rassurés quant à leur devenir
aujourd'hui que les taux de décrochage
d'insertion professionnelle et de
poursuite d'études réussies les
encouragent à être rassuré dans le
système de lycée professionnel alors
pour la première fois le président de la
République une première ministre et tout
un gouvernement se mobilise pour que le
lycée professionnel soit une voie de
choix une voie reconnue une voie qui
permette effectivement de construire
l'avenir souhaité et nécessaire pour ces
jeunes alors comment nous allons faire
tout simplement par le fait que j'engage
pleinement les lycées professionnels
dans le choc des savoirs eux aussi
doivent pouvoir effectivement avoir plus
d'enseignements fondamentaux c'est ainsi
qu'ils auront plus 10 % d'enseignement
fondamentaux et je propose aux
organisations syndicales c'est
actuellement concertation plus un/ers de
ma tique de français d'histoire géo
d'éducation morale et civique pour la
terminale plus que cela nous allons
également travailler par des
sous-effectif dès la seconde seconde
première pour faire mieux de
l'enseignement en mat et français dans
la veine de ce qu'engage Gabriel Atal
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse sur l'ensemble de notre
système scolaire nous allons également à
travailler le projet de l'élève pour lui
permettre une insertion professionnelle
ou une poursuite d'études réussies si ça
c'est son projet et l'année de terminale
repensée va permettre cela nous allons
également encourager les formations
d'avenir parce que placer le lycée
professionnel dans un avenir c'est le
placer au cœur des grandes stratégies et
puis nous allons faire du lien avec les
entreprises au travers du mentorat des
bureaux des entreprises de ces ces
enjeux d'attractivité des filières parce
que ces jeunes il le méritent et nous
allons travailler pour
cela merci beaucoup madame la
ministre 4 secondes allez-y monsieur
Corbi madame grand pas de baratin rendez
les merci ex je vous remercie la parole
est à Monsieur Christophe Maron pour le
groupe Renaissance merci madame la
Présidente après une 3è édition réussie
de la semaine des lycées professionnels
je souhaite adresser ma question à
madame Carole grandjan ministre délégué
chargé de l'enseignement et de la
formation professionnelle madame la
ministre vous avez récemment annoncé les
contours de la nouvelle version de
l'année de terminale pour les élèves de
lycée professionnel le calendrier serait
ainsi composé de 30 semaines communes à
tous à ce bloc commun 22 semaines de
cours six de formations en milieu
professionnel et deux d'examens
s'ajouteraiit alors des semaines
personnalisées selon les projets des
élèves 6 semaines de cours afin de
préparer l'enseignement supérieur pour
ceux qui ambitionneraient de poursuivre
leurs études ou 6 semaines de stages
supplémentaires pour ceux qui
choisiraient d'entrer dans le monde du
travail et je salue la possibilité qui
sera offerte aux élèves de modifier leur
choix de parcours personnalisé en
fonction de leurs premières impressions
et surtout de leur résultat de leur
résultats parcours sup votre proposition
qui s'inscrit dans le cadre de la
réforme des lycées professionnels que
vous menez depuis plus d'un an répond au
besoins d'accompagnement à l'insertion
professionnelle des élèves ainsi qu'à la
nécessité de faciliter pour les lycéens
la poursuite d'études mais vous le savez
madame la ministre vos annonces
inquièteent certains syndicats
d'enseignants témoignent la grève en
cours dans nos établissements
professionnels je sais que vous êtes à
l'écoute de leurs préoccupations et que
vous les recevez régulièrement à votre
ministère mais l'une de leurs
inquiétudes parle au députés d'une
circonscription rurale que je suis les
élèves souhaitant s'insérer dans la vie
professionnelle trouveront-ils partout
des entreprises prêtes à les accueillir
IR pour un stage de 6 semaines en fin
d'année scolaire alors même que les
secondes seront en stage à la même
période et trouveront-il des entreprises
prêtes à les embaucher éventuellement
par la suite une attention particulière
et donc est-elle donc portée au lycée
professionnel situé dans les bassins
d'emploi moins dynamique plus
généralement alors que des inquiétudes
sont exprimées ici et là pouvez-vous
nous rassurer quant au respect de
l'équilibre dans le cadre de cette
réforme entre enseignement professionnel
dans et hors de l'établissement et
enseignements généraux je vous remercie
merci beaucoup mon chers collègue la
parole est à madame Carole Grandjean
ministre en charge de l'enseignement et
de la formation
professionnelle merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député Christophe
marionon je sais votre engagement et
votre attachement à la jeunesse à
l'école à l'avenir de ses élèves et aux
enjeux de la ruralité je voudrais
effectivement vous réaffirmer toute
l'ambition du gouvernement une ambition
inédite pour faire réussir ces jeunes
c'est un/ers des lycéens qui qui passe
par la voie professionnelle et nous
devons changer de paradigme pour mieux
les faire réussir je le rappelle seul un
élève sur deux parvient à s'insérer dans
l'emploi à l'issue de son parcours de
formation et seul un élève sur deux
parvient à réussir sa poursuite d'étude
lorsqu'il l'engage il s'agit donc pour
moi d'engager une transformation
profonde et à plusieurs niveaux je le
redis je prends toute ma part dans le
choc des savoirs pour que ces jeunes
puissent avoir une acquisition des
savoirs fondamentaux qui leur permettent
de travailler évidemment leur
citoyenneté et leur avenir professionnel
c'est donc plus 10 % en terminal
d'enseignement fondamentaux et jusqu'à
plus d'un tiers que je propose dans le
cadre du dialogue social actuellement en
cours en math en français en Histoire
Géo en éducation morale et civique pour
mieux les préparer c'est également des
sous-effectifs que je propose en seconde
et première pour permettre de faire
mieux des mathématiques et du français
et de s'ajuster à leur difficultés alors
autour de ce Tron commun ils seront
effectivement tous ensemble dans cette
progression pour qu'il prépare mieux et
qu'ils réussissent mieux leur bac et
autour de ce bloc personnalisé on
accompagne le projet de l'élève soit
vers la poursuite d'études et avec une
préparation à la poursuite d'études de 6
semaines soit sur un stage qui soit
tremplin vers le premier emploi
trempelin vers le premier emploi parce
qu'encore une fois un élève sur deux qui
souhait s'insérer dans l'emploi n'y
parvient pas et je souhaite que nous
travailons sur ces jeunes sans solution
à l'issue de leur bac j'ai annoncé aussi
des mentions mentions au Cap aux brevets
professionnels au aux mentions
éémentaire parce que je crois aussi dans
la reconnaissance de l'excellence de ces
jeunes parce que beaucoup d'entre eux
sont dans cette démarche là et c'est
inédit il faut leur reconnaître
l'excellence je souhaite aussi valoriser
le bureau des entreprises qui va nous
aider à travailler tout au long de
l'année notamment avec un dispositif
nommé avenir professionnel pour les
aider à trouver le bon stage ce stage
qui leur permettra d'être le premier
emploi pour eux demain je l'espère merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup madame la
ministre la séance de question au
gouvernement est terminée la séance est
suspendue